if you had to guess the number one cause
of mortality in the world you might say
cancer disease or even car accidents
which is no doubt pretty high in the
list but the number one cause of
mortality is myocardial infarction
better known as a heart attack heart
attacks are caused by atherosclerosis or
plaque buildup in your arteries research
from the last two decades has shown just
how prevalent this disease is and how
early in life it affects you which you
may find shocking in this video I'll be
discussing the dark science of
atherosclerosis
foreign
[Music]
just as the heart supplies blood and
oxygen to organs in the body the
coronary artery delivers blood and
oxygen to the heart itself as it's a
working muscle a heart attack occurs
when the coronary artery becomes blocked
with a blood clot thus stopping blood
flow and oxygen to the heart the
coronary artery is fairly large with a
diameter of four millimeters or the size
of a drinking straw the artery becomes
blocked when the arterial wall ruptures
due to excessive plaque buildup within
the wall when the artery ruptures plaque
and clotting factors are released into
the blood these clotting factors cause
red blood cells to stick together and
form clots which then blocks blood flow
the question is how did the plaque get
there in the first place two factors
explain why LDL cholesterol and blood
vessel inflammation cholesterol is a
sticky fatty lipid found in red meat
processed lunch meats butter baked goods
and fried foods it's essential for
development of cell membranes and
production of vitamin D we acquire most
of it through our diet but it can be
made in the liver when supplies are low
cholesterol like any nutrient has to be
transported throughout the body to reach
cells for nutrition being a fat and
having a non-polar structure cholesterol
is insoluble in blood since it's 90
percent water therefore cholesterol has
to be transported by a specific carrier
protein called A lipoprotein your body
has two kinds of lipoproteins high
density label protein or HDL and low
density lipoprotein or LDL HDL and LDL
differ by where they transport
cholesterol to HDL picks up excess
cholesterol and transports it to the
liver where it's converted into bile by
contrast LDL transports cholesterol to
cells all around your body since HDL
removes excess cholesterol and only has
one route it's in your blood for a
shorter period of time and is called
good cholesterol by contrast LDL has
multiple routes in your body and has
more exposure time in the blood it also
has multiple sugar groups on its surface
making it extra sticky because it's in
the blood for a longer period of time
and has sticky sugars LDL is known as
bad cholesterol and gets stuck in your
arterial walls
but how does it get there but first A
fitting sponsor for today's video ag-1
ag-1 is a foundational nutrition
supplement that is formulated to raise
your Baseline Health by supporting the
whole body brain and gut each scoop
provides important vitamins antioxidants
probiotics and minerals that Supply
important nutrition and keeps your body
healthy but seriously it really does
help your overall health a single scoop
of ag-1 has a complete daily required
intake of vitamin C vitamin E vitamins
B1 B2 B7 B12 niacin zinc and folate to
match this nutrition from food you would
have to eat multiple serving sizes of
oranges eggs berries meat nuts seeds and
leafy vegetables with ag-1 all you need
is a single scoop and eight ounces of
water this host of important vitamins
and minerals are key to fulfilling your
daily nutritional needs antioxidants
counteract free radicals in your body
thereby supporting cardiovascular health
and Metabolism daily intake of vitamin C
and Zinc is crucial to managing your
immune system when you subscribe your
welcome kit will come with a 30-day
supply of ag-1 a shaker bottle a
canister for storing ag1 powder a liquid
tincture of vitamin D3 and K2 and a
30-day supply of ag-1 travel packs from
my own experience ag-1 gives me more
energy throughout the day to where I'm
drinking less coffee to stay awake and
no longer rely on pre-workout to have a
thorough exercise beyond having more
energy and my nutritional needs met I
find I'm less stressed and have better
focus and Clarity after having taken ag1
for just a few weeks head to drink
ag1.com forward slash dark science to
get a free one-year supply of AG vitamin
D3 and K2 plus 5 ag1 travel packs with
your first purchase of ag-1 you can find
the link in the description below
because it's in the blood for a longer
period of time and has sticky sugars LDL
is known as bad cholesterol and gets
stuck in your arterial walls but how
does it get there this is where blood
vessels come into play blood vessels are
made of special cells called endothelial
cells these cells form tight junctions
to retain Integrity of the blood vessel
handle pressure and retain fluids
however being exposed to blood
endothelial cells also come in contact
with inflammatory substances in the
blood whether you eat drink or smoke
everything you put in your body gets
absorbed into your bloodstream when you
consume inflammatory substances like
trans fats saturated fats sugar tobacco
byproducts and alcohol they all get
absorbed into the blood consequently
these inflammatory molecules come in
contact with endothelial cells and
damage them over time as endothelial
cells become damaged their tight
junctions lose integrity and become
slightly permeable known as endothelial
dysfunction
LDL cholesterol being sticky and having
more exposure time in the blood tends to
accumulate in these permeable openings
in the vessel and gets wedged into the
arterial wall once LDL gets stuck it
stays there forever in this mechanism
when you ingest more cholesterol by
eating red meat butter fried food and
baked goods you increase the amount of
cholesterol in your blood and
subsequently increase the chances of
cholesterol getting stuck in your
arteries once inside the arterial wall
LDL becomes oxidized by free radicals
which triggers nearby macrophages to
engulf the LDL cholesterol macrophages
are housekeeping cells that clean up
waste such as cell debris and consume
foreign substances to protect the body
macrophages recognize oxidized
substances as a threat and therefore
isolate it from the body by engulfing it
once inside the macrophage cannot leave
and is there forever as more LDL
cholesterol enters the arterial space
the macrophage continues to engulfate as
the macrophage consumes more LDL it
becomes engorged with cholesterol and
becomes what's called a foam cell
accumulation of enlarged foam cells in
the arterial wall greatly contributes to
plaque buildup in the artery if things
couldn't get worse when foam cells reach
their End Cycle like all cells do their
cell membrane breaks down and they
release all their cellular components
including tons of cholesterol
macrophages being housekeeping cells are
signaled to clean up cell debris when
cells break down and do so even when
foam cells break down in the artery new
macrophages enter the arterial space and
consume debris and cholesterol this
vicious cycle continues for decades
additionally calcium phosphate salts in
the blood make their way into the
arterial wall and deposit in the plaque
forming a substance called
hydroxyapatite which is the main
component found in bone and teeth
formation of hydroxyapatite causes the
arteries to calcify and Harden making
arteries less flexible and responsive to
blood flow this arterial hardening is
known as sclerosis in Latin and is part
of the word atherosclerosis which means
pasty hardening at some point plaque
builds up to where the arterial wall
loses structural Integrity usually at
the shoulder section of the Bulge where
it's most weakest the arterial rupture
releases cholesterol fats and most
importantly clotting factors into the
bloodstream these clotting factors cause
red blood cells to clot together
creating a blockage in the artery when
clotting happens in the coronary artery
the heart cannot receive oxygen and a
heart attack ensues from here medical
responsiveness determines the outcome
one thing I found truly disturbing about
atherosclerosis is just how early it can
occur in young people you would think
the presence of plaque in your arteries
is something specific to people with
poor diet over a long period of time in
two famous studies from the Journal of
the American Medical Association
researchers conduct an autopsies on
American soldiers from the Korean and
Vietnam conflicts the purpose of the
study was to see if there was
significant plaque buildup in their
coronary arteries
in 1953 300 male soldiers were autopsied
from the Korean front with an average
age of 22 years they found that 77
percent had overwhelming evidence of
plaque buildup in their coronary
arteries and 35 percent had arterial
hardening something that was believed to
have occurred many years later in life
the second study in 1971 autopsied 105
American soldiers from the Vietnam
conflict also with an average age of 22
years 45 percent had atherosclerosis
prior to these findings it was believed
that plaque buildup was something that
didn't occur in young people especially
those who were in Peak physical
condition what's even more alarming is
recent Studies have shown that
atherosclerosis can occur at younger
ages than previously thought in 2008 the
Journal of Canadian Cardiology
investigated plaque buildup in fetuses
and infants of mothers who smoke
cigarettes in the study mothers were
selected who smoked between 5 and 20
cigarettes a day prior to pregnancy and
after giving birth additionally 48 of
the mothers in the study smoked during
their pregnancy autopsies were performed
on 22 fetuses and 36 infants who passed
from natural causes researchers found
soft plaque lesions in coronary arteries
of 83 percent of fetuses and 94 of
infants along with reduced diameter of
the arterial lumen
in comparison to non-smoking mothers
plaque was found in only 20 percent of
fetuses and 15 percent of infants in
2002 the Federation of experimental
biology also found that pregnant mothers
who had a diet high in cholesterol gave
birth to infants with plaque buildup
during my childhood I recall being told
by adults not to worry about being
overly concerned about the food I ate I
was told not to worry about heart
problems till I got older there is some
truth to this as you won't get a heart
attack at nine years old but as we've
seen plaque accumulation can happen at
any age based on diet and lifestyle
though a child won't get a heart attack
the plaque you have in your arteries at
60 or 70 was probably first put there
when you were a child again based on
diet and most kids and teens have a poor
diet you would think with the Advent of
the internet and improvements in
medicine that people would be more aware
of their health and eating right
unfortunately that doesn't seem to be
the case by the age of 40 roughly 50
percent of people have significant
plaque buildup in their arteries since
2000 heart attacks have increased
annually from 2 million to 8.9 million
in 2019.
atherosclerosis is an irreversible
condition the oxidized cholesterol foam
cells cell debris and LDL lipoproteins
are there forever however you can reduce
the amount of plaque that accumulates in
the future avoid food that causes
inflammation to your endothelial cells
foods high in trans fats saturated fats
refined carbohydrates sugar and smoking
cause inflammation and blood vessel
cells which allows LDL cholesterol to
accumulate in arterial walls foods high
in trans fats also known as hydrogenated
fat are processed foods meant to have
long shelf life such as margarine
processed baked goods microwave popcorn
non-dairy creamer and fried foods foods
high in saturated fat and cholesterol
are pretty much the same as trans fats
except we add to the list red meat
cheese ice cream and butter a healthy
low cholesterol diet includes lean
protein such as poultry and fish
vitamins and antioxidants from fruits
and vegetables and ample fiber from nuts
and whole grains fruits and vegetables
provide antioxidants which reduce
inflammation by quenching free radicals
and fiber from whole grains and nuts
binds to Sticky cholesterol in your
small intestine preventing it from being
absorbed into your blood this video is
not intended to make you a hypochondriac
or to be fearful of french fries it is
true that atherosclerosis occurs at any
age even as a fetus infant or a
physically fit young adult however the
last decade has seen advances in
medicine today about 90 percent of
people survive heart attacks this is due
to advances in heart attack procedures
such as stents and bypass surgery
ultimately this video aims to show you
the very real and early effects poor
diet and lifestyle can have on the body
when it occurs and how you can make
better choices
sometimes science can be seen as
difficult foreign and even boring yet
there are times when science grabs our
attention and draws Us in yearning for
more answers often what draws us Center
topics that are dark Macabre or
terrifying it's with the intention of
this video that you too were drawn in
and sought to have your questions
answered thanks for watching Dark
science
thank you